[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
bienvenue dans sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportage sur Public Sénat on est
ensemble tous les jours du lundi au
jeudi à 18h et 22h pour donner du sens à
l'actualité grâce à nos experts nos
chroniqueurs et nos reporteurs la trêve
se prolonge à Gaza mais jusqu'à quand
cette question tout le monde se la pose
des familles d'otage détenu depuis 54
jours jour au diplomate du monde entier
en passant par les civils palestiniens
qui redoutent la reprise des combats qui
mène les négociations le Hamas sait-il
précisément combien d'otages sont
toujours vivants la guerre peut-elle
reprendre sous une forme différente on
en débat dans une minute et puis dans
l'actualité de ce 29 novembre il y a
aussi la COP la COP 28 qui s'ouvre
demain à Dubaï je vous propose un zoom
sur l'une des conséquen majeur du
réchauffement climatique la fonte des
glaces
polaires
vous entendez parler du réchauffement
climatique mais ici on constate c'est ça
le
message les gens qui vivent ici ceux qui
viennent souvent comme nous on voit les
glaciers on peut témoigner d'une mission
à l'autre quel est l'impact du
réchauffement
climatique monté des EAU réfugiés
climatiqu nouvelle route commerciale
exploitation minière nouveau virus la
liste des défis est longue très longue
vous le voyez ne ratez pas l'analyse de
nos invités dans 3IS qu4 d'heure mais
d'abord donc la situation en Israël et à
Gaza alors que le ramas propose de
prolonger la trêve de 4 jours Jonathan
Dupriez vue désert Gaza ressemble à un
champ de
ruine au sud de la ville les riverins
constatent incrédule que leurs
habitations ont été ravagées par des
semaines de combat c'est tout ce qu'il
reste d'une vie de labeur ce que j'avais
de plus cher était dans cet endroit mes
enfants mon mari même s'il n'est plus de
ce
u mais etaceune tout a disparu au 6e
jour de trêve la bande de Gaza vit un
court moment de répi répi que les
organisations internationales jugent
bien insuffisant au vu de l'ampleur de
la crise humanitaire qui couve la moitié
des hôpitaux de l'enclave sont en
service quelques 30000 blessés seraient
en attente de
soins à terme les maladies vont tuer
plus de personnes que les bombardements
si nous ne sommes pas en mesure de
remettre en place ce de santé et de
fournir des denrées vitales de base de
la nourriture de l'eau des médicaments
et bien sûr du carburant pour faire
fonctionner les hôpitaux si la trêve a
permis de faire entrer les ONG dans Gaza
elle a surtout permis de libérer un
important contingent d'otage 81 à ce
jour échanger contre 180 détenus
palestiniens les médiateurs
internationaux Qatar Égypte et surtout
les États-Unis se démultiplie pour
obtenir un arrêt durable des combats le
secrétaire d'État américain se rent en
Israël en ce sens au cours des prochains
jours nous nous efforcerons de faire
tout notre possible pour prolonger la
pause afin de pouvoir continuer à
évacuer davantage d'otage et apporter
davantage d'aide humanitaire le Hamas se
dit prêt à prolonger la trêve de 4 jours
et une nouvelle libération d'otage
pourrait avoir lieu ce mercredi de son
côté l'État hébreu affiche toujours sa
fermeté Benjamin netanahou a réaffirmer
vouloir libérer tous les otages du Hamas
et prévient qu'Israël reprendra les
combats après la trait
combien de temps cette trêve peut-elle
durer on en débat avec anneesophie sban
bécage bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
directrice de l'Américan gwish commite à
Paris et docteur en géopolitique
Guillaume Ansel bonsoir et bienvenue
écrivain ancien officier auteur du blog
ne pas subir ééonor veille bonsoir et
bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
indépendante vous avez notamment
travaillé pour le quotidien israélien
Arz et Mathieu croissand éditorialiste
politique bonsoir Mathieu cette trève
elle est fragile Anne Sophie c'est bamb
qu'est-ce qui pourrait l'interrompre
aujourd'hui ce qui pourrait
l'interrompre c'est la décision de
l'armée israélienne de reprendre
l'opération militaire pour finir de
remplir les objectifs qui s'étaient
fixés c'est-à-dire de de neutraliser la
capacité de nuisance la capacité
militaire du ramas elle se finit
normalement cette trêve demain il y a
des négociations en cours pour qu'elle
se poursuivent eu les les possibilités
pour qu'elle se poursuiv vont dépendre
de la nature de ce qui est de ce qui
pourra être négocié de ce qui qui
figurera dans cet accord mais certains
enfin ce qui pourrait conduire Israël à
à accepter un accord qui permettrait de
poursuivre la trêve ce serait la
libération de tous les otages mais aussi
la le la la démilitarisation de Gaza le
fait que ramas le ramas dépose les armes
ce voilà ça pourrait être un moyen de de
ne pas de ne pas poursuivre cette
opération militaire mais les objectifs
d'Israël sont dans les enfin sont les
mêmes ils ont été rappelés il ne
risquent pas de de changer rquer le
Hamas et de l'empêcher de de nuir
Guillaume el pourquoi le Hamas propose
une trêve plongée de 4 jours est-ce que
c'est c'est lié au nombre d'otage qu'il
est sûr de détenir d'une certaine façon
parce que c'est une vraie question ça ou
en fait une question qui est cruciale
dans cette négociation sur la libération
d'otage c'est que aucune des deux
parties ne sait exactement combien
d'otage il y a les Israéliens avaient
estimé d'ppord à 240 on pense que assez
malheureusement naturellement il y en a
une vingtaine qui ont dû mourir en
arrivant sur Gaza à cause de leur
blessurees initial ou des mauvais
traitements qu'ils ont reçu c'est un
total de 220 il y en a 90 aujourd'hui
qui auront été libérés faites le décomte
il faudrait réintégrer à l'intérieur le
nombre d'otages qui ont été tués pendant
l'offensive israélienne qui à mon avis
sont quasiment aussi nombreux donc en
fait on sait pas très bien si on reste
entre 60 et 100 pas plus et donc les
Israéliens sont très méfiant et ils ont
raison de l'être parce qu'en face le
Hamas ne sait même pas combien d'otage
il lui reste en vie R parce que les
otages pardon nous interrompre ils ont
été entre guillemets dispatchés au sein
de différents groupes différents lieux
et cetera on sa que les les otages dans
ces situationsl sont toujours dispersés
parce que ce serait prendre des risques
énormes que d'avoir un seul groupe on
imagine mais c'est assez courant dans ce
genre de malheureusement situation que
ce sont des groupes entre 5 et 10 otages
donc ça fait une quarantaine de cellules
différentes qui ont été réparties sur
l'ensemble du territoire de Gaza comme
les Israéliens ont détruit à peu près
un/ers de la bande de Gaza avec les
bombardements de toute façon
mécaniquement on sait qu'il y a un
certain nombre de cellules qui ont été
détruites mais que le Hamas ne connaît
même pas parce que ce sont des équipes
des cellules qui sont très mal coordonné
et donc les patrons du Hamas avec qui on
essaie de discuter au Qatar ne savent
pas quelle est la réalité sur le terrain
et les Israéliens ont une liste qui ne
veulent pas dévoiler pour l'instant de
d'otagees qui sont décédés mais ils
attendent de savoir ce que le Hamas va
mettre sur la table pour dire non ça
c'est c'est pas vrai et d'ailleurs c'est
une des raisons pour lesquelles le Hamas
refuse que la Croix-Rouge internationale
aille visiter les otages parce que un
ils ne savent pas où ils sont et deux
ils ne veulent surtout pas qu'on sache
quelle est la réalité du nombre qui
reste ééonorveille la la société
israélienne est-ce qu'elle est partager
sur cette question que pèsent ceux qui
militent pour une reprise des combats
écoutez c'est c'est un dilemme
aujourd'hui qui frappe la société
israélienne parce que d'une part il y a
quand même cette ce ce ce débat autour
de de la sécurité de recouvrer un
sentiment de sécurité après les
massacres du 7 octobre mais aujourd'hui
je pense qu'il y a quand même un
consensus on peut dire qu'il y a un
consensus autour de cette priorité qui
est le retour du plus d'otagees possible
et tant qu'on a l'espoir de retrouver
ces otages en vie euh la majorité des
Israéliens mis à part une petite partie
de l'extrême droite israélienne et pour
cet objectif de guerre contrairement au
premier qui avait été affiché qui est
l'anilation la
destruction du Hamas aujourd'hui voilà
ce que ce que disait monsieur Ansel
c'est effectivement le Hamas prétend
qu'il ne peut pas aujourd'hui localiser
l'ensemble des otages on a entendu
surtout cette famille Bibas dont on
parle beaucoup ces dernières heures C
derniè semaine on va on va sûrement
reparler qui sont devenus vraiment le
symbole de cette de cette prise d'otage
et qui serait aujourd'hui aux mains du
FPLP donc un autre groupe à l'intérieur
de de la bande de Gaza mais il y a aussi
cette crainte que le ramas joue un jeu
cynique en ne pas voulant divulguer ce
qu'il sait ou ce qu'il ne sait pas en
jouant aussi sur cette complexité de
retrouver les otages pour prolonger le
CESS le feu ça fait aussi partie du jeu
de guerre du du ramas et de la
propagande mais mais c'est aussi ce que
vous nous avez dit c'estàd que l'armée
israélienne ne dit pas tout non plus
parce que au fur et à mesure de sa
progression elle a quoi elle a découvert
des corps des dizaines de corps c'est ça
en particulier dans la partie nord de la
bande de Gaza ou l'armée israélienne
essaie d'en prendre le contrôle total
aujourd'hui elle en contrôle à peu près
40 % ce qui pose d'ailleurs question
pour la suite parce que ce que ça aurait
du sens qu'elle se retire s'il y avait
un cessé le feu définitif alors que son
but c'était de cont contrôler
complètement cette zone mais dans les 40
% qu'il contrôleent aujourd'hui en
particulier dans les tunnels qui ont été
très durement bombardés ils ont retrouvé
de nombreux corps décédés je vous laisse
imaginer que c'est terriblement
difficile d'identifier en général c'est
des prélement ADN qui permettent de
confirmer que mais il y a plusieurs
dizaines d'otages qui ont été retrouvés
morts et donc la question c'est de
savoir comment on met à jour cette liste
alors que le Hamas ne le sait peut-être
même pas mais pardonnez-moi je je je
j'ai pas eu cette information euh on en
avait déjà parlé lors d' d'unun d'un
autre plateau que l'armée israélienne
aurait retrouvé des corps-morts ce qu'on
sait en revanche c'est que quand l'armée
israélienne est arrivée à l'hôpital
alchifa et sous les tunnels il y a eu
effectivement des corps qui ont été
retrouvés ceux de Judith Weiss et de de
la soldate Noa Martiano et que ça a tout
de suite été euh publié et annoncé par
l'armée israélienne et que je je je ne
comprends pas pourquoi il y aurait cette
volonté de dissimuler euh les otages
morts alors que euh dans ce cas précis
ça avait été tout de suite communiqué à
l'ensemble de de l'opinion publique
israélienne alors sur le nombre d'otages
déjà libérés Jonathan donnait dans son
sujet 81 il y a eu deux otages russes on
a appris ça aussi aujourd'hui donc on
serait à 83 60 otages israéliens 23
otages étrangers en majorité des
Thaïlandais et et donc en contrepartie
180 détenus palestiniens qui ont été
libérés le Premier ministre Benjamin
netaniao ça fait partie des déclarations
de ce mercredi il confirme il l'avait
déjà dit auparavant que les combats
reprendront juste après la
trêve ces derniers jours on m'a posé une
question après avoir achevé la prise en
charge de nos otages est-ce qu'Israël va
reprendre les combats ma réponse est oui
sans équivoque il n'y a pas
d'arrangement nous reprendrons les
combats jusqu'au
bout c'est ma politique mon cabinet de
sécurité y adhère et l'ensemble du
gouvernement aussi les soldats
soutiennent cette politique le peup est
derrière nous et c'est pour ça que nous
agirons en ce
sensopis Bage il y a une dimension
géopolitique aussi qui est la pression
américaine que que tente d'obtenir la
diplomatie américaine de benamin
netanahou dans l'éventualité d'une
reprise des combats des combats sous une
autre
forme ou alors une trêve qui se prolonge
le plus longtemps possible qu'est-ce
qu'on en sait aujourd'hui alors qu est
ce qu'on en sait c'est que le président
américain essaie de faire en sorte que
cette trêve se poursuive au moins déjà
de de quel quelques jours pour permettre
la libération de plus d'otages notamment
la libération de tous les otages
américains ce serait un succès une
avancée pour les États-Unis et et et
pousse aussi pour que cette trêve se
poursuive en en arrêt prolongé des
combats c'est un c'est un c'est un jeu
intéressant entre entre Israël et les
États-Unis car on sait par ailleurs que
les États-Unis soutiennent très
fermement ils l'ont répété à plusieurs
reprises Israël dans cet objectif de
guerre qui est l'éradication du ramas en
tout cas la neutalisation de sa capacité
de nuisance donc je pense que tout va se
jouer aussi
dans ce coneit des objectifs atteints
par l'armée israélienne aujourd'hui ce
qu'il en coûterait pour Israël demain de
poursuivre ses objectifs qu'est-ce qui
reste à faire aujourd'hui pour
neutraliser cette menace et qu'est-ce
que les Américains vont demander à
Israël en contrepartie héonorveille une
guerre sous une autre forme ça pourrait
être quoi aujourd'hui ce que demandent
les Américains à Israël d'ailleurs les
les Américains et les Israéliens
semblent avoir des intérêts
contradictoires puisque benamin
netanahou et son cabinet de sécurité
continueent à dire chaque jour que la
guerre reprendra dès la fin de ce cesser
lefeu et de manière forte et et et
jusqu'au bout et que les États-Unis
espèrent utiliser cette trêve en tout
cas cette période de de de de oui de
calme de trêve ou de cesser le feu pour
changer l'aspect de de cette guerre et
la la la peur aujourd'hui de de de
Washington c'est que les combats se
concentre cette deuxième phase de la
guerre se concentre dans le sud de la
bande de Gaza là où je vous rappelle que
des millions de Palestiniens on on fuit
le nord pour se rendre dans le sud et là
euh vous allez sûrement être d'accord
avec moi la la la campagne militaire
israélienne sera encore plus compliquée
avec une population encore encore plus
surabondante et la peur de perdre civil
supplémentaire donc là Washington va
peut-être mettre son véau et d'ailleurs
Joe Biden a déclaré pas plus tard
qu'hier que pourrait reprendre cette
campagne militaire mais qu'il faudrait
éviter à tout prix un nouveau
déplacement des populations civiles
palestiniennes donc israël va se
retrouver face au mur et va devoir faire
des choix face à à son allié de de
toujours amé y a trois temporalités
différentes la première si on est
logique avec l'opération militaire qui a
été lancée je rappelle qu'elle a été
décidée par le gouvernement néalien ou
bien sûr c'est pas de Sal qui décide de
ses opérations ce serait d'aller
jusqu'au bout du contrôle de la partie
nord de la bande de Gaza or actuellement
je rappelle que l'armée israélienne ce
matin on contrôlé un peu plus de 40 %
pas plus donc sil reprenaiit leur
offensive ce serait bien sûr déétendre
totalement leur contrôle ne serait-ce
que pour se dire on n'est pas passé à
côté quelque chose d'important parce
qu'on nous a demandé nous retirer très
vite la deuxième temporalité ça au sol
ça nécessite à mon avis plusieurs
semaines sans doute deux à tro semaines
on sera déjà mi-décembre et là ensuite
la question c'est une fois qu'on a la
partie nord la bande de Gaza qu'est-ce
qu'on fait de la partie Sud est-ce qu'on
sait on essaie de mener des raides mais
dans une population qui est
incroyablement pardon concentrée et là
on sait que c'est un carnage si on veut
mener une opération terrestre ou est-ce
qu'on accepte qu'une grande partie du
Hamas des miliciens du Hamas se soi
échappés dans le sud et que quelque part
ils soit hors de portée ou alors l'armée
israélienne peut aussi pardon pas
l'armée israélienne le gouvernement
netaniaahou décider que cette partie
nord une fois qu'elle a été quasiment
détruite devient un espèce de nansland
dans lequel il ne laisse pas les
Palestiniens sur R saler en disant on
veut une zone de sécurité une zone
tampon troisième solution ils sortent de
la partie nord mais à ce moment-là ils
peuvent pas prendre le risque le Hamas
reprennent le contrôle de la bande de
Gaza sinon franchement c'était pas la
peine de faire ça et donc là se poserait
la question de c'est quoi l'autorité
internationale une autorité temporaire
provisoire pas l'ONU parce qu'on connaît
son inefficacité on l'a mesuré ne
serait-ce qu'avec la finule mais une
autorité provisoire mené par quelques
pays qui dit moi je m'assure que en
attendant qu'il y ait une véritable
Autorité palestinienne qui émerge c'est
en discussion ça déjà bah c'est déjà
dans des plans qui sont chez Joseph
Borel pour l'Union européenne et en
particulier chez les Américains qui
disent il faut qu'on ait une autorité
provisoire qui permet de reconstruire la
bande de Gaza sans qu'il y ait aucune
possibilité d'agression contre Israël et
ça ça nécessite un pouvoir fort qui va
maîtriser ce qui se passe et on sait que
notamment l'Égypte est assez intéressé
d'avoir une comment dire une vision très
rapprochée ne serait-ce que pour que les
Frères musulmans ne réapparaissent pas
dans un paysage voisin je rappelle que
les Israéliens refusent catégoriquement
euh que l'Autorité palestinienne prenne
le contrôle aujourd'hui en tout cas de
la bande de gaz je paris d'une Autorité
palestinienne he pas de celle-ci celleci
d'accord et làdessus juste pour revenir
sur ce qui se joue aujourd'hui dans les
négociations avec les États-Unis Israël
je crois qu'on peut pas en parler aussi
sans parler du rôle du Qatar qui
aujourd'hui joue ce rôle dans la
négociation des otages mais il y a quand
même une grande question qui va se poser
ensuite qui doit déjà se poser dans ce
qui est négocié dans cet accord c'est
euh quel rôle voudra jouer le Qatar
est-ce qu'il voudra euh continuer à
défendre les intérêts du ramas ou ceux
des Palestiniens est-ce que le Qatar
aujourd'hui est capable de faire
pression sur le ramas pour obtenir des
garanties de sécurité pour Israël
également qui permettrait une
acceptation d'une trêve plus longue qui
permettrait de se mettre d'accord sur
sur des opérations enfin sur une
poursuite de cette situation différente
qu'une simple reprise de l'opération
militaire par par Israël le catar
évidemment qui est à la manœuvre mais
guillaumeel on parlait des deux Russes
qui ont été libérés aujourd'hui là c'est
un autre c'est un autre canal en quelque
sorte de discusion nég y a deux
négociations parallèles qui ont été
menées c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que le
gouvernement israélien en a peu parlé
parce qu'elle estime que c'était quelque
part c'est pas elle qui a négocié ça les
Thaïlandais ont négocié directement avec
l'Iran en se s'appuyant beaucoup sur la
Malaisie qui je le rappelle est le plus
grand pays musulman du monde et et par
conséquent ils ont un lien particulier
avec l'Iran et Israël a dit moi je si
vous menez une négociation à part je
pardon mais je je m'inscris totalement à
l'écart c'est pour ça qu'on sont pas
dans les décomptes et c'est vrai que ça
a été un peu surprenant ça n'a pas été
critiqué c'est très bien que ces otages
soient libérés c'est des otages libérés
et puis les Russes ont un lien
particulier avec le Hamas on se souvient
qu'il y a un an le ministre des Affaires
étrangères de Poutine lavov était venu
visiter les dirigeants du Hamas on s'est
tous demandé à l'époque ce qu'il venaent
discuter avec le Hamas et je pense que
les Russes ont une implication dans
cette affaire qui est beaucoup plus
grande qu'elle ne laisse'afficher
jusqu'ici récemment une délégation du
ramas qui est qui est qui est venu qui
qui s'est rendu à Moscou et je vous
rappelle que le premier homme qui a été
libéré dans C dans cette première salve
de libération d'otage c'était un russe à
la demande spécifique de Vladimir
Poutine donc c'est c'est ça ça montre à
quel point Vladimir Poutine a un poids
dans cette dans ces négociations alors
j'ouvre un autre chapitre parce que vous
l'avez évoqué euh tout à l'heure on
reste évidemment sur le sort des des
otages mais l'une des information de ce
mercredi après-midi c'est cette annonce
du Hamas qui annonce la mort de trois
otages un bébé son frère et sa mère et
la nveille je reste avec vous c'est
cette famille dont le sort a été
particulièrement médiatisé les Bibas
pourquoi sont-ils devenus l'un des
symbole des massacres du 7 octobre bah
tout simplement parce qu'il s'agit d'un
d'un bébé qui avait 9 mois qui en a
maintenant 10 et d'un petit garçon de de
de 4 ans et de leur maman on a vu ces
images terribles parmi d'autres images
hein qui ont circulé depuis le le 7
octobre de cette mère affolée qui tient
ses enfants et qui sont pris par les
terroristes du ramas dans la bande de
Gaza donc c'est leur c'est le plus jeune
otage d'abord ce ce ce petit Kfir Bibas
et c'est vrai que les les Israéliens
retiennent leur souffle depuis l'annonce
de cet accord d'otage chaque jour je
peux vous dire qu'ils sont tous à se
demander est-ce que les deux petits rou
sont dans la liste des des des personnes
libérées et chaque jour c'est une
déception le le cousin de ils sont ils
sont rou c'est ça avec il y avait des
ballon orange qui symbolisait symbolisit
le le sort tout à fait il y a le le le
le cousin de la famille donc de de la
mère chiri Bibas qui s'est exprimé de
nombreuses fois notamment sur la chaîne
12 et qui disait que il vivait un
supplice évidemment que c'était comme la
La Liste de Schindler si vous voulez
tous les jours ils reçoivent des listes
ils espèrent que le le le les noms de
leur famillees figurent sur ces listes
et chaque jour ils sont déçus alors
cette annonce du ramas il faut la
prendre quand même avec des pincettes
parce que je rappelle que une autre
otage Rana katsir voilà avait été
annoncé morte par par le Jihad islamique
et qu'elle a été libérée il y a quelques
jours donc voilà encore une fois c'est
c'est extrême prudence et et à l'heure
où où on enregistre l'émission où on
vous parle en cette fin d'après-midi on
n pas encore de confirmation de la part
de de l'armée israélienne qui qui
cherche à à confirmer c'est évidemment
la la question de la responsab si
personne ne le souhaite mais si ces
décès sont confirmés je vais vous poser
la même question à l'une et à l'autre va
y avoir
un bras de fer macabre pour se rejeter
la responsabilité de la de la mort de
cette famille c'est le Hamas dit c'est
les bombardements israéliens et on verra
ce que Israël dit ce sera le cas pour
pour tous les otages qui n'auront pas
été récupérer de toute façon le Hamas
dira qu'ils ont été tués à cause des
bombardements israéliens et les
Israéliens diront en tout cas le
gouvernement netanahou oui mais c'est
grâce à notre offensive euh qu'on a pu
libérer d'autrees otages là où à mon
avis le gouvernement netanahou n'est pas
net c'est que c'est pas à cause de son
offensive qui libère des otages c'est à
cause de la pression de la société
israélienne qui est extraordinairement
enfin pour qui la vie est d'une
préciosité incroyable c'est pas le cas
du Hamas et qui dit un otage c'est sacré
et donc vous n'avez pas le droit de
sacrifier les otages et puis la pression
des Américains qui veulent sortir de ce
tunnel qui est la guerre parce que les
américains ils ont le sentiment que la
guerre que mène actuellement le
gouvernement netaniaahou est une impasse
dans la mesure où les patrons du Hamas
de toute façon ils sont au Qatar et que
ce qu'on estimait être les forces du
Hamas que que personne ne sait quantifié
elles se sont enfuies vers le sud et par
conséquent on est en train de taper dans
le vide on l'a bien vu avec le sketch de
l'hôpital alchifa on avait annoncé le
quartier général stratégique du Hamas et
malheureusement on a trouvé que des
tunnel pour l'essentiel vide h Anne
Sophie bcage votre avis sur ce c'est ce
qui va se jouer là dans les prochains
jours encore une fois ESP ça n'est pas
confirmé espérons
que il n'y aura pas de confirmation du
décès de cette famille mais voilà va y
avoir va y avoir une guerre de
communication là aussi oui bien sûr elle
existe déjà cette guerre de
communication on a vu comment leas ce la
libération des premiers otages tous les
jours en leur demandant de de les saluer
en essayant de moner qu'est-ce qui
pourrait on va en parler un peu plus
tard de ça par vous interrom qu'est-ce
qui pourrait permettre d'affirmer avec
certitude qui est responsable ou non de
la mort de cette famille excusez-moi
mais à partir du moment on responsable
c'est ceux qui les ont enlevé bah voilà
je dire cette question n'a pas lieu
d'être par mais je suis d'accord avec
vous mais mais je comprends cette
question parce qu' elle est légitime
mais mais qu'est-ce que F un ENF sûr
mais si c'est un bombardement dans un
bombardement Isra même chose'est change
qu'est-ce que ça change et c'est ce que
disait la famille la famille de ses
enfants elle disait mais c'est le ramas
qui les a kidnapper c'est le ramas qui
est responsable de les ramener en vie
et voilà rentrer dans dans dans ces
considérations est-ce qu'ils sont morts
pendant leur captivité ou à cause des
bombes israéliennes finalement c'est
vraiment ne pas voir le problème qui est
qu' un enfant de 10 mois et un enfant de
4 ans n'ont rien à faire ça personne ne
pourra dire le contraire de C il faut
voilà il faut il faut recentrer le débat
sur ça et que si s'avère après que c'est
des frappes israéliennes ce sera
évidemment terrible mais les
responsables si jamais cette famille
avait péri c'est le Hamas ou et le FPLP
et le Djihad islamique et oui encore une
fois pourquoi ces bombardements aussi
enfin je veux dire ces bombardements
malheureusement sont une réponse à
l'attaque du ramas du du 7 octobre et
quand on voit aussi les pertes de de
soldats israéliens on on oublie souvent
de de le de le préciser mais ces soldats
et ces familles qui doivent renvoyer
leurs enfants à
l'armée vivent aussi un un drame
humain j'ai jamais sur ce plateau
sous-estimé ce qui pouvait être l'impact
de des massaces terroristes du 7 octobre
sur la société israli est-ce que ça
représentait est-ce qu' était la
responsabilité du Hamas évidemment mais
il y a quand même aussi une question sur
la stratégie
guumsel de Benyamine netaniaahou du
cabinet de guerre sur cet objectif
d'éradiquer le ramasse enfin bon je je
suis pas le seul à le dire beaucoup de
spécialistes m'ont dit sur ce plateau il
est quasiment inatteignable donc jusqu'à
quand on va bombarder pour un objectif
qui est sans doute stratégiquement
inatteignable ce qui est extrêmement
gênant c'est que tout ça ressemble à un
incroyable piège tendu par le Hamas
parce que dans son attaque bestiale le 7
octobre qui n'était absolument pas
justifié ils avaiit aucune raison de
massacrer comme ça les gens on réalise
bien que ce qu'il voulait c'était
provoquer une réaction disproportionnée
du gouvernement israélien et aujourd'hui
on a une espèce d'inversion de situation
on a l'impression que c'est quasiment le
Hamas qui a la bienveillance et
l'humanité de rendre quelques otages je
rappelle que faire les otages c'est un
crime de guerre les massacres du 7
octobre je pense que maintenant tout le
monde les connaît 10000 morts une
sauvagerie inouie ils ont fait ça pour
emmener Israël là où il le souhaitait et
ce qui est terrible dans la réponse de
netaniaou c'est qu'il a jamais de
stratégie élaborée il dit d'une main je
veux détruire le Hamas mais de l'autre
on a l'impression qu'il a fait le lit du
Hamas regardez de qui on parle
aujourd'hui du Hamas on a l'impression
que la Palestine la bande de Gaza c'est
le Hamas pour moi c'est une erreur
stratégique d'autant que les buts de
guerre
d'éradiquer un mouvement terroriste tous
les pays qui ont été confrontés à des
mouvements terroristes le savent la
solution militaire n'est pas complète
bien sûr qu'il faut lutter contre mais
c'est pas en envoyant des chars mercavin
qu'on va détruire le Hamas l'armée du
Hamas et d'ailleurs l'armée israélienne
le dit très bien pour l'instant le Hamas
fait extrêmement attention de pas se
battre contre sal elle serait écrasée
immédiatement donc elle s'évapore des
unot un mot qu un mot quand même
là-dessus parce que c'est pas
uniqueement je dire n'importe quel autre
Premier ministre d'Israël là
effectivement c'est le gouvernement
netanahou et on sait ce qu'on sait de ce
gouvernement et il y a quand même eu un
gouvernement d'union nationale dans dans
la crise donc c'est plus le même
gouvernement qui qui qui était là avant
le 7 octobre mais n'importe quel autre
Premier ministre d'Israël aurait rosté
militairement face à cette at c'est je
suis d'accord avec vous que c'est que la
la réponse militaire ne peut jamais être
la seule réponse et qu'on ne peut pas
venir au bout euh qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire éradiquer le ramas de toute façon
l'idéologie on l'éradiquera pas
maintenant faire en sorte que pour au
moins quelques années pour au moins une
décennie les populations du sud d'Israël
soient en sécurité que le Hamas ne
puisse pas se réarmer réengager une
offensive c'est déjà un objectif qui est
atteignable euh je veux dire on on verra
dans les mois qui viennent dans les
semaines qui viennent ce qui se passe
mais euh seul une opération militaire
permet de neutraliser au moins ce que
disait Joe Biden ne refaites pas les
erreurs qu'on a commises après non bien
sûr je dire face à daesh par exemple la
coalition internationale est-ce qu'elle
a totalement éradiqué daesh elle a elle
a fortement réduit sa capacité de
nuisance sa capacité de projection de de
d'organiser des attaques est-ce que ça
veut dire qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a plus
de combattants DAEs il n'y a plus de de
terroristes qui se réclam de cette
organisation et de cette idéologie non
mais quel enfin quelle autre réponse
pouvait-on envisager face à l'attaque du
7 octobre je vous pose la question et je
nous pose la question collectivement
Mathieu et pour prolonger la question de
Thomas est-ce que en fait le le le but
de guerre é radiquer le Hamas c'était
compatible avec exiger et retrouver la
libération de tous les otages oui je
crois que c'est un c'est un double
objectif il ne pouvait que reposter
militairement et engager dès le départ
comme ça a été fait des négociations
pour pour la libération mais c'est une
bonne question non mais bien sûr que
c'est une bonne question mais quelle op
quelle autre option était je je moi je
je vais vous parler uniquement d'un
point de vue militaire il se trouve que
j'ai conduit des opérations d'extraction
on a un choix très dur à faire à ce
moment-là soit on lance une offensive
contre ceux qui détiennent les otages
soit on va récupérer les otages mais
c'est pas la même chose et quand le
gouvernement netanahou a pris ce choix
de lancer une offensive terrestre très
dure très très violente contre la bande
de Gaza il savait que les otages serit
passeraiit dessous et d'ailleurs le fait
qu'il plusieurs dizaines d'otages je
vous dis sans doute à peu près le nombre
des otages qui vont être échangés ça
montre bien que malheureusement en
prenant cette option là ils savaiit
qu'il sacrifi un certain d'otage et ce
qui est étonnant c'est que maintenant il
essaie de vendre à tout le monde que
c'est grâce à son offensive qu'il permet
de libérer les otages alors que c'est
pas grâce à son offensive c'est parce
que la société israélienne a exigé une
trève bien c il le voulait pasment ça
arrange aussi le ramas qu je dire le
ramas a quand même été affaibli et a
besoin aujourd'hui de jours de trêve
pour se réorganiser pour se réarmer pour
se déplacer pourquoi pourquoi est-ce que
le ramas a pris des otages sinon pour
pour prendre en otage Israël et pour se
donner une une une porte de sortie une
possibilité à un moment de de se réarmer
de seréorganis der motus je je pense que
c'est important de d'essayer de
comprendre aussi quelle
est difficile à dire mais quelle est la
la stratégie du ramas si en effet ce
n'est pas les taux qui se resserraient
autour de de de de ces de cette branche
militaire qui a permis la libération de
et je ne suis pas experte militaire donc
je je ne le sais pas qu'est-ce qui a
fait que y sin noir a accepté cet accord
ce deal et se cesser le feu est-ce que
le cesser le feu c'était pas justement
un besoin pour le ramas de se réarmer de
souffler de et ça voudrait dire que les
taux se resserraient autour du ramas
donc où est d'un point de vue militaire
seulement comment on explique que ils
ont accepté cet accord et à quel point
le le les prisonniers Palestiniens
étaient un un point important aussi dans
la stratégie du Hamas le Hamas pour moi
attendait patiemment que à cause de la
pression interne et externe notamment
des États-Unis mais aussi des Égyptiens
ils soit mis comme interlocuteur comme
un acteur étatique incontournable qui
aujourd'hui est vu par le monde entier
comme étant le seul interlocuteur viable
de la bande Gaza c'est exactement ce que
cherchait le Hamas qui l'a dit dans une
déclaration New York Times il y a 3
semaines qui a dit 1 on veut installer
un état de guerre permanent avec Israël
exactement ce qu'a fait Israël et
deuxièmement on veut montrer que c'est
nous la repr présentation des paltinens
alor ils ne sont
pas Deven quand on lit les derniers
sondages en Jordanie est en tête des
sondages il est maintenant oui alors on
va continuer de de parler de du sort des
des otages et peut-être de leur
condition de détention je vous propose
d'abord un témoignage celui de ID dan
proche de deux adolescents qui ont été
libérés mais son nouvelle de leur
père deux de nos enfants bien-aimés SAR
16 ans et Rs 12 ans viennent d'être
libérés par le Hamas et ont atterri sur
le toit de cet hôpital avec
l'hélicoptère de
l'armée nous sommes pleins de joie de
bonheur mais en même temps nous sommes
très un qui pour leur père mon cousin
offer Calderon qui est toujours en
captivité j'accueille audre V sur ce
plateau bonsoir audre donc grâce à ces
témoignage des proches des otages eux
mêmees on commence à en savoir un petit
peu plus sur leurs conditions de de
détention oui même si les autorités
israéliennes appellent à la plus grande
discrétion sur ces conditions les otages
ont d'ailleurs été briffés avant de
pouvoir retrouver leur famille des
bribes d'informations nous proviennent
on découvre que ces conditions de
détention étaient bien différentes selon
les otages certains étaient retenus dans
des tunnels sans pouvoir voir la lumière
et ce pendant 50 jours de très longues
journées des nuits à dormir assis sur
des chaises les uns contre les autres
comme dans une salle d'attente parfois
il fallait attendre près d'unehure et3
pour pouvoir aller aux toilettes une
hygiène précaire même si les ravisseurs
faisaient leur maximum pour éviter les
maladies c'est ce qu' a rapporté une
exotage qui a été libérée après 2
semaines de
captivité ils se sont assuré que nous
avions tout ce qu'il fallait que les
toilettes étaient propres pour que nous
ne tombions pas malades ils avaient peur
de la
peste évidemment leurs conditions de
détention ont empiré au au fur à mesure
que les jours passaient oui notamment en
matière de nourriture les otages
expliquent qu'ils mangeaient au début un
peu comme leur ravisseurs des pitas du
fromage frais des concombres au fur et à
mesure les rations ont commencé à
s'amenuiser un peu de riz un peu de pain
de manière très irrégulière parfois pas
tous les jours comme l'explique une
responsable d'un service d'urgence qui a
pris en charge ses
exotages les personnes qui arrivent ont
perdu beaucoup de poids en très peu de
temps moins 10 % de leur masse voire
plus ce qui constitue un problème
médical elles ont été nourres avec des
aliments très peu nutritifs et qu'en
est-il des enfants et bien on en sait un
peu plus grâce au témoignage de la
famille d'an ce Français de 12 ans qui
vient d'être libéré on découvre que les
enfants n'avaient le droit de jouer qu'
cartte ou de dessiner interdiction de
parler à voix haute sous peine d'être
tué en tout cas c'est les menaces qu'ils
entendaient une emprise psychologique
qui dure encore maintenant au moment où
les enfants ont été rendus à leur
famille certains ne s'exprimaient qu'en
chuchaotant alors évidemment ça pose la
question maintenant du choc
psychologique pour ces enfants qui ont
été en captivité pendant de très longues
semaines merci merci beaucoup Audrey on
va continuer de parler de peut-être on
l'a évoqué rapidement et je me tourne
vers vous Matthieu de la de la guerre de
communication de la guerre des des
images en quelque sorte il y a il y a
ces images de libération d'otage depuis
depuis quelques jours comment sont-elles
mise en scène qu'est-ce moi ce qui me
frappe déjà sur l'échelle du conflit
c'estàdire depuis le 7 octobre c'est
qu'on a jamais eu autant d'images elles
n'ont jamais été aussi nombreuses d'une
certaine façon elles n'ont jamais autant
prêté à caution elles n'ont jamais été
aussi contrôlé et puis
n'ont peut-être jamais été autant mis en
scène et ça on retrouve dans les trois
séquences du conflit d'abord dans le
fait générateur avec le Hamas qui filme
les atrocités terroristes qu'il commet
le 7 octobre donc c'est quand même assez
inédit dans l'histoire qu' que des
criminels de guerre des terroristes
enfin les terroristes il en avaient déjà
eu mais que que dans ce type de conflit
on filme des atrocités d'habitude les
agresseurs les plan disent ben non c'est
pas nous on n jamais fait ça là il les
filme pour les terroriser ensuite on
passe dans la la phase de ripost
israélienne et là le Hamas ne cherche
plus à terroriser il cherche à émouvoir
et on a toutes les images qu'on a vu
après les bombardements de père avec des
enfants dans les bras et puis là il
cherche il utilis les images aujourd'hui
pour triompher dans cette période de
cesser le feu en montrant le le Hamas
bienveillant avec les otages à qui on
demande continue de faire coucou s'il te
plaît et puis enfin des des trucs
absolument délirants et puis le retour
des des prisonniers palestiniens donc il
est à la fois triomphant sur son
territoire libérateur voilà et en face
Israël dans ces trois phases a toujours
été sur la défensive dans la première
celle du fait générateur elle va
réutiliser les images du Hamas pour
dénoncer c'est pour que les gens dans la
communauté internationale croisent ce
qui s'est passé et réalisent ce qui
s'est passé dans la seconde partie
c'estàd celle de laarost tandis que le
Hamas chercheait mouvoir israël va
chercher à se justifier et ça donne ces
images un peu délirantes qu'on a vu à
l'hôpital d'alchifa où ils sont obligés
d'aligner trois kalashnikov et des
choses qu'ils ont trouvé pour prouver
que ils sont dans leur bon droit de de
de reposter et là dans cette dernière
phase mais eux y a évidemment toutes les
émotions qu'on voit dans dans les
rassemblements de famille en Israël et
je trouve que c'est incroyable que que
que cette inversion comme ça de de de de
l'utilisation des images dont le Hamas
sort vainqueur il faut le dire en tout
cas jusque jusqu'à présent et juste pour
finir je trouve qu'on a de plus en plus
d'images mais d'une certaine façon de
moins en moins d'éducation à l'image
parce que l'opinion publique
international est saisi abreuvé sur les
réseaux sociaux toutes ces images qui
circulent plus personne n'est capable de
les contextualiser plus personne n'est
capable de les comprendre parce que
avant on on ne croit que ce que l'on
voit ça c'était avant comme comme saint
Thomas aujourd'hui on ne voit que ce que
l'on croit et donc même quand vous avez
des images qui vous arrivent en pleine
figure on dit bah non ça NAA pas existé
c'est pas ça jusqu'à pour finir
puisqu'on en parle sur ce plateau ces
visages d'otage qui sont tellement
dérangeants pour certains qui ne veulent
tellement pas y croire qu'ils se
précipitent pour les arracher dès qu'il
les voi afficher merci Mathieu je
voudrais qu'on parle des Palestiniens
qui ont été libérés par Israël en
contrepartie de de la libération des
otages donc des détenus palestiniens je
vous propose un témoignage un homme son
fils de 14 ans était le plus jeune des
tenu Palestiniens
écoutez par que Ahmed était en prison
nous ne pouvions pas lui rendre visite
bien qu'il soit le plus jeune prisonnier
palestinien lorsque la guerre a commencé
le 7 octobre nous avons perdu tout
contact avec notre
fils que sait-on Guillaume Ansel des des
otages enfin pardon le lapsus je m'en
excuse des détenus palestiniens qui ont
été libérés par Israël al en fait Israël
rend beaucoup de prisonniers en échange
des otages hein dans un ratio de 3 pour
un qui est pas tout à fait exact parce
qu'en fait Leamas a libéré un peu plus à
cause de ce qu'on a dit tout à l'heure
sur les Thaïlandais les Russes mais ce
sont des prisonniers sans importance
pardon mais il y a absolument
aucun aucune figure de prou
palestinienne à l'intérieur ce sont des
gens qui condition m par Israël tout à
fait ce sont des gens qui sont en
attente de jugement parce que ils ont
commis des délits ou euh des des crimes
mais pas des crimes de sang depuis le 7
octobre et que en fait ils étaient
emprisonnés en attente d'être jugés et
en fait pardon mais Israël s'en
débarrasse un peu parce que de toute
façon c'est pas des gens qui auraient
passé des années en prison et ils n'ont
pas de poids dans l'évolution de la
situation politique on ne parle pas de
bargouti on ne parle pas des leaders
palestiniens qui sont en prison h et
pour moi beaucoup plus de sens de
négocier SAF que mon avis le Hamas tient
pas tellement à récupérer bien sûr on
aucun intérêt à les faire libérer
surtout surtout bargouti par Marwan
bargouti qui est emprisonné depuis plus
de 20 ans et qui était effectivement
l'un des leaders palestiniens an Sophie
c'est
bambéach il faut peut-être revenir un
peu en arrière là aussi la libération de
du soldat Guil Chalit alors là c'était
contre un millier de de de détenus
palestiniens quelle leçon Israël
tire-t-elle de ce qui s'était passé à
l'époque sur l'identité de de de de
celles et ceux qui avaient été sortis
des prisons israéliennes mais ce qui
s'était passé à l'époque est ce qui a
beaucoup ému l'opinion publique
israélienne c'est que parmi ces 1000
prisonniers palestiniens il y a en effet
le commanditaire principale de l'attaque
du du 7 octobre et ce qui est ce qui est
un élément qui qui me
semblait nous permett de dire que le
ramas a quand même été affaibli c'est
effectivement le ratio qui a quand même
changé euh dans le nombre de
Palestiniens de de détenus palestiniens
libérés en échange des otages et et ça a
été effectivement pour le soldat
gilashit un prix très lourd à payer pour
Israël mais qu'Israël était prêt à payer
que la société israëlne était prête à
payer pour sauver pour sauver cette vie
et qui serait et qui qui est toujours
prête à le faire on m'a posé la question
de est-ce qu'il y a un changement une
évolution dans la stratégie sur la
libération des otagesen je je crois pas
je crois que à chaque fois
malheureusement Israël est dans une
situation comme vous l'avez décrite hein
très compliqué sont des pièges tendus
par ces organisations terroristes mais
la volonté de de tout faire pour pour
les libérer jusqu'à libérer voilà
jusqu'à libérer des des il y a des
soldats dans lesages oui est-ce qu'on
peut imaginer que le ratio change quand
il s'agira de libérer les soldats alors
c'est justement le le c'était le le
sujet des discussions de la Réunion quad
partite qui a qui a qui a eu lieu hier
euh à DOA entre les chefs des
renseignement américains que égyptien
médiateur cataris et le chef du mossade
euh on parle de cinq catégories hein de
de d'otage les femmes et les enfants euh
les hommes les hommes les soldats actifs
et les les les personnes âgées et les
corps des soldats parant c'est c'est
cinq catégories en tout et il est
question aujourd'hui ça fait partie des
discussions d'une future libération
d'hommes en âge d'être soldat donc de
potentiel réservistes et de soldats il y
a aucune confirmation aujourd'hui sur un
accord potentiel de libérer des soldats
mais ça fait partie aujourd'hui des
négociations est-ce que le nombre de
détenus palestiniens pourrait changer
mais mais voilà comme on disait le ramas
n'a pas forcément intérêt à libérer tous
les prisonniers palestiniens puisque
certains prisonniers palestiniens sont
des figures emblématiques de l'Autorité
palestinienne qu'il pourrait euh s'il
s'ils étaient libérés s'il revenaent en
sis-jordanie euh avoir une certaine
légitimité un certain pouvoir et du coup
voler un peu le le la vedette du donc ça
aussi ça ça va faire partie de des
négociations de ces prochains jours qui
qui est à la manœuvre qui sera à la
manœuvre dans les prochains jours
imaginons que cette trêve se prolonge
est-ce que ça peut se transformer en une
négociation plus vaste plus large alors
le le le point sémantique c'est que on
fait souvent on oppose trêve à cesser le
feu alors que ça veut dire la même chose
mais sauf que dans notre esprit et c'est
normal c'est un usage la trêve c'est
temporaire un cesser le feu c'est
l'amorce d'une sortie du du tunnel de la
guerre et ce que veulent les Américains
très clairement c'est qu'on sorte de la
guerre pour deux raisons la première
c'est que ils n'ont aucune confiance
dans les buts de guerre qui ont été
affichés par netaniaou ils pensent ils
ont quand même pas mal d'expérience sur
le sujet notamment les talibans qui sont
allés chercher en Afghanistan qui a été
une vraie catastrophe que de toute façon
ils sont inatteignbles et donc ils
disent plus vite on sera sorti de ça
mieux ce sera et la deuxième chose c'est
que on se rapproche des élections
présidentielle aux États-Unis et qu'il y
a une partie de la société américaine
qui dit attendez nous on a toujours
défendu Israël
mais pas les carnages qui sont en train
d'être commis dans la bande de Gaza et
par conséquent ça ce n'est pas possible
de continuer comme ça pourquoi parce que
le Hamas a créé de la part du
gouvernement netanahou une confusion
entre le Hamas et les Palestiniens de la
band c'est exactement ce que voulait le
Hamas et c'est de là d'où veulent sortir
les Américains qui ne veulent plus voir
ces images on en parlait tout à l'heure
absolument atroocce d'hôpitaux dans de
de de mè avec leur enfants qui a été tué
donc on voit bien que les Américains
veulent sortir et pour eux sortir c'est
une fois qu'on aura goûté au cesser le
feu c'est arriver à apaiser tout le
monde et dire maintenant il faut qu'on
trouve un moyen de sortir de là ce qui
est très difficile an Sophie c'est mais
est-ce que c'est pas de plus en plus
difficile de repartir en guerre si le si
cette trève dur oui j'ajoute un point je
pense sur les raisons qui qui expliquent
pourquoi les États-Unis veulent veulent
que ça s'arrête c'est aussi que si le le
conflit se poursuit il y a un risque
bien sûr un risque voà il y a un risque
d'escalade régionale qu'on a réussi à
éviter pour le moment grâce notamment à
la force de de dissuasion américaine
mais les intérêts américains ont été
menacés il y a toujours cette menace qui
pèse au nord d'Israël avec le hzbolah il
y a toujours le risque que l'Iran entre
dans le jeu et la reprise des
hostilités ferait durer ce risque on
voit aussi comment l'Arabie Saoudite
essaie de jouer un rôle à offert
aujourd'hui et depuis le 7 octobre à
l'Iran d'augmenter ses investissements
et sa coopération en échange de de de
l'assurance de la part de du régime desm
là qu'il ne qu'il ne créerait pas
d'escalade et qu'il ne voà ne ne ne
déclencherait pas ses proxis pour pour
élargir le conflit donc il y a vraiment
cet aspect-l qui est important à
l'approche des élections sachant que le
conflit ukrainien euh n'est pas terminé
euh ce serait euh ce serait désastreux
pour les États-Unis qu'un autre front
s'ouvre merci à tous d'avoir participé à
ce débat je vous dis à bientôt sur sur
Public Sénat